you know our city has really become
quite the sports city definitely has a
lot has changed the same you know been
over here like 10 years long time big
changes since then my parents came they
even noticed they're like wow it's so
different I mean even within months
changes here absolutely and there's even
talk of a professional men's basketball
team coming here Candace Charles joins
is live from Pro Sports RX Vegas where
many of the NBA players train and get
medical attention hey Candace
good morning YouTube good morning folks
that's definitely going to be an
exciting weekend here in VidCon coming
here as they just mentioned we've really
become a huge sports city of course with
our wonderful golden knights taking home
that champ we love to see it and the
aces as well we got the Raiders now and
there's been talks about possibly
getting that NBA team you know LeBron's
been talking about that quite a bit
hopefully it'll come true we got the
white Ross here with us now from Pro
Sports RX you guys have some of the
players that come down here NFL players
a little bit as well tell us a little
bit about what goes on here
uh well the guys come in here and they
and they start with treatment so so
we're just basically keeping them
healthy their only job now is to stay
healthy stay out of trouble right
collect a check absolutely absolutely I
know a lot of them will be here for NBA
con what can people expect of this week
gosh you're gonna see uh uh celebrities
athletes uh uh everybody in town from
Agents to to financial advisors even uh
they're having a
uh wealthcon I think is another thing
that's going on here so just just
everything that an athlete would want
and even the general public can get
around and see it and all the fun and
games they're making it for kids too so
so there's a lot of fun things going on
here absolutely another big thing we've
talked about like I said is Vegas
becoming this huge sports city any
predictions about us actually getting
that NBA team what have you been hearing
well I just talked to somebody last week
in power that helped with the A's and
help with the Raiders getting here and
she seems to stink uh insists that
there's an NBA team coming and they were
building something and they will come
interesting so we shall see thank you so
much white for chatting with us and for
all you do in the community we
appreciate it and you guys can find out
more about Pro Sports RX on the website
newsnow.com of course we'll be covering
nba.com because they got you covered
with a closer look so join us tomorrow
morning for that but for now live from
Pro Sports RX off of Dean Martin 15 I'm
Kansas Charles 8 news now all right good
stuff Candace so she's gonna go join
that guy behind her doing the Sprints
okay